she is an actress comedian host of
hulu's i love you america now in its
second season my favorite sarah
silverman is over here
[Applause]
television you do it i don't know either
well as you can see i'm starting to lose
it
it always happens at the end of the
season anyway uh i before we get to the
politics congratulations
you got your walk your walk your star
on the walk of fame today
there it is oh my god welcome to the
club
i'll be here i have one you do it's
right next to gary busey
oh you're kidding not the star actually
gary
you know in a time
bill where anti-semitic crime is up 57
since this douchebag has taken office it
is not lost on me
that i am very lucky that i get a star
and i don't have to sew it on my
[Applause]
i don't know if clothes gallows humor or
uh just like it's funny cause it's true
humor well
i think it's they love sarah silverman
humor
oh thanks no i meant that
genuinely me too you know when you're a
comic and everyone thinks you're
sarcastic
i love your dress they go [ __ ] you
exactly so your show is fantastic i was
on it this week i was honored to be
there
and uh you know you do a great service
you go out and you talk to people who
are
outside of our little bubble here in
hipsterville
and you don't even know what oat milk is
[Laughter]
poor dears um and uh do you think you're
changing any minds out there
uh probably not yeah but i'm
i'm changing mine i mean not politically
not
not ideologically but you do realize
there's a difference but
a bit of a difference between the the
liars and the lied to
do they though no of course not right
they don't know they're lied to it's
like cults cults don't know they're
right
well and one good thing though i must
say about trump
is i never thought i'd even say those
words
but he has sort of broken down certain
norms that we lived with for a long time
that didn't really make sense like
extramarital affairs i mean i was
arguing with that in the clinton days it
doesn't really matter that's private
it doesn't remember they used to say if
he cheats on his wife is he going to
cheat on the country
no doesn't make any sense you can cheat
on your wife all day long and still be a
good president we've had many who did
uh another one language betto
said uh i love the [ __ ] out of you guys
at his rally
years ago that would have been a big
deal because he said [ __ ] no nobody
gives a [ __ ]
it's true and i like i i like when
people use [ __ ] in a positive way that's
how my dad i always grow up and my dad
says [ __ ] every other word but he's a
joyful guy i'm such a [ __ ] lucky guy
you know like he's
it's joyful and i think that's nice i
don't like when trump says stuff like
stupid
and loser and stuff like that to me
that's um you know i'm not
the word police he can say it but it
just says so much about himself and i
we all know he's really kind of at this
arrested development at about eight
years old
right genuinely yeah this isn't it's
true
yeah and i would have great compassion
for him if
if he wasn't hurting people's lives but
those are words that children say before
they learn that those
that they're not nice words you know
you're a loser you're stupid
yeah that's that's a bad karma what
about [ __ ]
uh i have okay you're setting me up and
i
but i do have a theory brought up [ __ ]
so you would say [ __ ]
oh you did i don't know i i everything
goes out the window once i'm sitting
here but
i think the this sounds silly but
we all of course on this show on where
i'm on too we can say [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] but but only those
it makes it really hard you have to
figure out um
but the rest of the country on on
television we just
and everything we accept that the word
[ __ ] is obscene
that it's a swear and
it just means poop it just means crap
there's no reason it should be
considered obscene or a swear at all but
we don't
question things that are just the way
they are and i think that it's
a an example of how
it's so [ __ ] hard to have any
progress because we don't question
anything nobody says why is [ __ ] bleeped
on tv
it just means poop poop isn't bleeped
crap
isn't bleeped duty isn't bleeped i'm
sorry i i
you hate that no i he doesn't like
you but you're but he loves me isn't
that the great idea but you're not
saying this is the most important issue
no i'm saying it's the least important
it's the least important issue because
you are just an example of how we don't
question anything that is just how it's
been well speaking of questioning what'd
you think of jim acosta
there getting
jim acosted you just made that up
yeah probably someone must have made
that up several times yeah it must have
um but that was a pretty amazing thing
to get thrown out of the press room and
also to to have a
press secretary sarah huckabee sanders
present a you said suckaby i did
yeah i meant succubus um
i didn't mean that see we're both losing
it but uh to to
submit a doctored tape like one degree
information exactly that's they get
their news from infowars i can't it's
par for the course of an authoritarian
government you know i mean it's it's he
it's not even dog whistles anymore it's
full-on who's a racist boy yes you
are right it's not subtle he's doing it
right in front of our [ __ ] face but
there have to be bad words i mean you've
got a president who's [ __ ] and we've
become accustomed to that
so what words are there for that nice
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one